write a vlogbrothers video in the style
of the King James Bible about whether AI
can write novels greetings fellow
vlogbrothers and sisters today I wish to
speak to thee about a topic that has
been on my mind of late whether AI or
artificial intelligence can write novels
first let us consider what AI is AI is
the ability of a computer or machine to
mimic intelligent human behavior it can
understand language make decisions and
even create art or music but can AI
truly write a novel to this I say it
depends on how we Define novel if a
novel is simply a lengthy work of
fiction then it is possible that AI
could generate enough text to meet this
definition however a novel is so much
more than a collection of words on a
page a novel is a story a journey a
tapestry of words woven together to
create something greater than the sum of
its parts can AI truly capture these
elements in its writing I say nay while
AI may be able to generate text that is
similar to human writing it cannot truly
understand the complexities and nuances
of The Human Experience it cannot
capture the unique perspective and voice
of a human writer it cannot create
something truly original and engaging
the way a human can in short while AI
may be able to generate text that
resembles a novel it cannot truly write
a novel in the same way a human can the
art of writing is a uniquely human
endeavor and it will always be so until
next time May thee be blessed with the
wisdom of the ages and the power of the
written word and as always don't forget
to be awesome Alright good morning Hank
it's Tuesday so that script was written
by chat GPT an artificial intelligence
and I have to say it's not the worst
vlogbrothers video I've ever come across
they even knew about dftba that noted I
uh I I I do have some concerns first off
I am super freaked out by that ai's
attempt to reassure humans like oh don't
worry you're super unique unique is one
of the only words it used twice oh no we
could never write a novel you don't need
to worry about that you cute little meat
person like I find that genuinely
scarier than if it had been like yeah of
course I'm gonna write the novels of the
future you idiot also it's interesting
that it relies so much on cliche like
phrases like window into the soul or
tapestry of words I think it's doing
that because they're somewhat evocative
but also common enough that it isn't
plagiarism but I think this gets
something important about how AI will
construct language like in order to
become more specific and textured and
compelling AI will need to rely Less on
cliche and use more unusual sentence
structures and of course the easiest way
to do that is to plagiarize or to
otherwise rely on particular human
brains now of course when I'm writing a
novel I am also deeply dependent upon
although linguistic constructions and
narratives that I've come across I am
also working from a data set all writers
are but I also think we have fairly
sophisticated strategies for deciding
what plagiarism is among humans and
maybe we don't so much for AI all also
I'm freaked out that this technology
means that we are already having
vitriolic arguments on Twitter and other
sites with people who are not actually
people but I'm not even sure that's my
biggest worry I think my biggest worry
might be uh
Consciousness like computers are amazing
but they are nothing like us we are far
far more like kangaroos than we are like
computers and I worry that as AI
improves we may begin to see human
consciousness and cognition as more
digital phenomena than organic ones
which I think would be a big mistake
like I think to be happy and also to
create the kind of word tapestries that
chat GPT tells me are uniquely human we
need to live as organisms on a planet
with other organisms I am not that
worried about attempts to make
technology more similar to us but I am
very very worried about attempts to make
us more like technology
Hank I'll see you on Friday they didn't
know about that one